انا اسمي ساميه عايش صحفيه ومدربه في
الاعلام الرقمي واركز على السرد القصصي
والابتكار في تدريباتي
[موسيقى]
انا ساره خضر باسم 2022 بلشت تدريب مع
سيان ان العربيه بوحده من التدريباتو فيها
الصحفيين والصحفيات ليدربون على اسس العمل
الصحفي بعتذر التدريب اخذت فرصه من الفريق
وانا اليوم فيديو صار لصفحه حكايتها
[موسيقى]
لما تعرفي القصه ولما تعرفي التعب اللي
بيروح به انه فعل هذا الشيء انت راح ديري
بالك عليه اكثر فراح يعيش اطول وراح يصفي
مش مرمي بمحل بارض فاضيه وياسر على
الطبيعه فهي كلها يعني
احنا لما بنحكي قصص اكثر هذا بساعد ايضا
في
تغيير العقليه المتعلقه بواقع النساء
وبيسلط الضوء ايضا على النجاحات التي
تقدمها المراه خصوصا المراه العربيه في
السنوات الاخيره
[موسيقى]
رده فعل المجتمع لما حكيت انه انا بدي
ادخل في مجال السيارات كان دائما بضحك انه
ايش سيارات اه اوكي يضحك
فيها شوي من الاستهزاء وبنفس الوقت انه اه
ان شاء الله اذا بطلع في ايدك
[موسيقى]
يمكن تلاقي هذا الدعم او يكون موجود هذا
الدعم بحياته
بس اهم شيء انه هي لتحقق اللي بدها اياه
يكون شي هي بتحبه
ومدخل شكوك غيره فيها يؤثروا فيها او حتى
الشكوك اللي هي بينه وبين نفسه ياثره فيها
[موسيقى]
النساء في المجتمعات العربيه بحاجه الى
الكثير من الامور المختلفه اول شيء نحن
بحاجه الى تغيير
جوهري في طريقه تفكير الناس وطريقه نظره
الناس نحو النساء بصوره عامه نحن بحاجه
ايضا الى تغيير في الكثير من القوانين
والكثير من التشريعات الخاصه بالنساء
في المنطقه العربيه نحن بحاجه ايضا الى
تشجيع المزيد من النساء نحو مشاركه هذه
القصص التي
يعيشنها بحاجه الى
مشاركهن ايضا الكثير من التجارب التي
يعني بيمروا فيها بحاجه ايضا الى ان
يتحدثنا اكثر عن هذا الواقع اللي عم
بيعيشوه بشكل يومي
عن جد بدي اوصل لمحل يكون قادره اترك اكبر
اثار اجابه ممكن اقدر اقدموه احب نفسي انه
انت فعلا قويه
وملهمه
وصبوره نسائهن عندهم دائما رساله سلام
الحقيقه وبيبعتوا هاي الرساله وبيسعوا
لالها
[موسيقى]